it was all about beating my dad earlier
on and a lot of that was because I felt
like a lot of the respect was withheld
from me earlier on and it was always
like a moving Target which is you know
if I got something wrong on a test it
was like would you get wrong that was
kind of the the earlier part was I
wanted to win the game that had been set
up for me first it was make a hundred
thousand a year and then it was made the
same amount of amount as my dad and then
it was make more than my dad and then it
was make more than my dad had ever made
his entire life and then once that
happened I looked around and I was like
I think I've been playing his game and
not my game I wasn't really setting any
rules I was just playing with the rules
that were given to me is this even the
game I want to play I think it did serve
me a lot and I don't know how much of
these reinforced behaviors that I
learned during that period of time still
benefit me today but they're not fueled
by the same thing so I still have these
habits of how I work and being dedicated
towards goals Etc that I think were born
of that but no longer are fueled from
that now